today the families of the five cyclists
killed by a dui truck driver will
testify in court it is now day two
of sentencing for jordan barson for that
horrible crash in her searchlight in
december
hector mejia now live at the courthouse
downtown with the very latest in this
good morning hector
hey there alex good morning this crash
affected so many people here in our
community and today jordan barson could
learn his fate
the 45 year old was under the influence
of meth when he
killed the five cyclists riding along
u.s 95
and barson appeared through a video feed
yesterday as family
of the five cyclists killed tried to put
their grief in words
back in april the 45 year old took a
plea deal he admitted to using meth
before driving the box truck in exchange
for pleading guilty to just two counts
of dui resulting in death
some family members broke down in tears
as they talked about losing their loved
ones
asking the judge to give barson the
maximum sentence
there was so much more he should have
been able to do
see and teach eli
but mr martin you took my dad away from
me
and eli at the start of the sentencing
hearing barson read a statement
he apologized and at one point appeared
to get emotional himself saying quote
i'm so ashamed of myself he said he
relapsed when he chose to do meth and
get behind the wheel
barson faces up to 40 years in prison
and we expect to hear for more family
members today
as they walk into the regional justice
center later on this afternoon
for another day of the sentencing
hearing reporting live in downtown
hector mejia
8 news now